[Musique]
et la chasse aux infos qu c'est ce soir
avec antoine penot bonsoir antoine envol
alors au menu ce soir tout d'abord cette
affirmation les états unis ont livré des
armes nucléaires à l'ukraine oui
absolument un choix d'une affirmation
qui a notamment sur qui les jeux les
réseaux sociaux et sur twitter en
particulier voici un exemple de
publication que j'ai trouvé pour vous
elle a été assez à la partager sur le
sur le réseau social c'est utilisateurs
lui affirme laisse que les états unis
ont transféré donc par erreur des armes
nucléaires tactiques à l'ukraine deux
ogives nucléaires affirme-t-il pour un
montant de 9 millions de dollars c'est
très précis et vous le voyez surtout il
accompagne cette affirmation de cette
photo cette photo d'un véhicule
militaire lance-missiles alors nous à
info ou intox on s'est demandé que
montre réellement cette image à l'aide
d'une simple recherche d'image l'inversé
on retourne sur cette même photo elle
est issue d'une banque d'image en ligne
qu'au bout des images que donc vous
pouvez acheter pour illustrer plusieurs
publications et vous le voyez elle
montre donc le système ima rth ce qui
est montré un peu en haut ici de lait
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs cette même
photo sur une page wikipédia consacrée
sur à ce fameux système i martin
systèmes déployés par l'armée américaine
et on apprend donc l'origine de ce
cliché sur wikipédia il était pris par
l'armée américaine voyez c'est marqué
ici en bas de la publication le on va le
voir ici 11 janvier 2005 très exactement
au centre d'essais de missiles de white
sands white sands vu qu'on est très
précis finalement à info intox on a
recherché sur google maps ou est-ce que
c'était white sands et regarder sa
seconde effectivement ici c'est au
nouveau-mexique exactement et c'est un
lieu bien connu parce que figurez vous
c'est là qu'a été essayé la première
bombe atomique de l'histoire c'était en
1945 à la mode garde aux voyageurs ce
monument commémoratif si l'on peut dire
d'un événement plus ou moins joyeux
selon selon certains à noter que ce
système il mars lui justement ces
systèmes antimissiles lui il va bien
être livré à l'ukraine c'est joe biden
qui l'a annoncé il s'agit d'un système
système d'artillerie à longue portée le
guardian vous le voyez ici notre le
journal britannique à d'ardeur proposer
un article détaillé sur le sujet il
explique donc notamment
la porte est relativement important de
ce système comparé aux autres systèmes
d'artillerie conclusion pas d'armes
nucléaires donc vous l'avez compris h
rennes mais une forte hausse sorti de
son contexte comme souvent et pourtant
cette un fox est tenace antoine elle
ad'ailleurs surgit également sous une
autre forme oui absolument h rennes mais
avec une autre photo mais vous allez
vous rendre compte que le propos est le
même quasiment au mot près là encore
cette même affirmation vous la voyez sur
ce twitt ces fameux deux ogives
nucléaires tactiques
toujours avec ce montant de 9 millions
de de dollars cet internaute qui dit ça
va être dur de démentir de qui se moque
t'on cette fois ci illustre son propos
avec un autre système de lance-missiles
que vous apercevez ici que nos enfants a
tenté bien on est têtu on a également
effectué une recherche d'image inversé
comme tout le monde devrait le faire sur
cette photo censée montrer donc des
missiles nucléaires on la retrouve là
encore sur une banque d'image en ligne
la voici il s'agit d'un cliché d'un
armement russe cette fois et non
américains le système lance missiles
iskander c'est très précis la photo date
vous allez l'apercevoir elle elle date
du 25 août 2020 elle a été prise à allah
binos et au sud de moscou lors d'un
événement qui s'appelle army 2020 c'est
un forum militaire qui est d'ailleurs
organisée chaque année par le ministère
de la défense russe coups ou presque et
d'ailleurs on est retombé sur la page de
l'événement de cette année a remis vous
le voyez 2022 qui est donc consacrée au
matériel militaire us donc ne s'agit pas
de missiles nucléaires américains
envoyés à l'ukraine mais le matériel
russe photographié lors d'un forum à
noter en revanche et pourrait tout à
fait exact que ce système balistiques
iskander est largement employés par
l'armée russe en ukraine il est équipé
de munitions conventionnelles mais il
peut également être équipés de charges
nucléaires npt voilà donc forcer un fox
le matériel militaire est aussi une
source de désinformation côté ukrainien
cette fois et vous avez un exemple oui
absolument l'allée des informations que
j'ai montré provenait plutôt de comptes
orienté pro russe vous l'avez
visiblement compris là ça va être l'un
verts savent être côté pro ukrainien
avec cette publication va retrouver nos
fameux lance-missiles 10 mars que je
vous avais montré au début de mon propos
tout part de ce post facebook vous le
voyez ici publié par un ukrainien qui il
affirme donc que c'est lance missiles
sont déjà arrivés en ukraine avec cette
photo à l'appui on voit ces camions à
stocker les uns à côté des autres dans
la cale d'un navire là encore on reprend
notre méthode de la recherche d'image
inversée h rennes et on tombe sur
plusieurs contenus abritant la même
photo en particulier cet article que
vous apercevez derrière moi il a été
publié sur un blog spécialisé dans les
questions de défense il détaille la
livraison à la roumanie vous le voyez de
18 lance-missiles y mars c'était le 20
février 2021 le blog nous précise qu'il
s'agira de la première livraison de cet
armement à la roumanie dans le port de
constanta très précisément la roumanie
qui a d'ailleurs commandé 50,4 véhicules
de ce type et leurs requêtes associées
parce que nous sommes décidément très
pointilleux info ou intox nous sommes
allés vérifier cette information sur le
site du ministère de la défense luc
romain pardon et on le retrouve
exactement le même cliché que vous
apercevez ici accompagné d'ailleurs
d'autres photos 1 vous voyez de lors du
déchargement de ses systèmes de lance
missiles depuis le navire avec la même
information dont première livraison de
systèmes immarsat la roumanie là encore
vous l'avez compris photo sortie de son
contexte conclusion le matériel
militaire et surtout sa méconnaissance
fait tourner les têtes et alimente les
uns fawkes évidemment merci beaucoup
antoine pour ce décryptage